[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20, Special Relativity.
So in this section,
we're going to review
the content of the
material, but underlined
with a few questions and
examples, very similar
to the previous section.
It's just this one is
interleaved with activities.
So let me start by bringing
back two of those Einstein
quotes, which nicely relate
to each other in a sense
that they feed off each other.
The first one is, "I
have no special talent.
I'm only passionately curious."
Albert Einstein.
And the second one, "It is
a miracle that curiosity
survives formal education."
And I [LAUGHS] sincerely
hope that I didn't stop
your curiosity
with this lecture--
quite the opposite.
Like we discussed here,
it's just the starting point
of a wider discussion
of general relativity
in your education at MIT
in the Physics Department.
You could learn about quantum
mechanics, quantum field
theories.
And a lot of physics
is out there,
which is super exciting
and interesting.
So it basically
needs your curiosity
in order to tackle challenging
questions in physics today.
We started the
discussion looking
at the background
which led Einstein
to make his discoveries.
And specifically the
year 1905, in which
he was able to come out with
five papers, all breakthrough
papers, including the theory
of special relativity.
His career didn't stop there.
He developed the general
theory of relativity
and published a paper
on this in 1915.
And his fame as a
physicist really
comes out of the predictions
he made at that time.
So we set the context
of this class,
and we started with a question
of Galilean transformation and
whether or not you can
tell in a moving train car
whether or not this is
actually moving or stationary.
And we demonstrated that
time and acceleration
is invariant in the
Galilean transformation.
And then, therefore, since you
cannot distinguish the strength
of a force in two reference
frames which move to each other
with moderate velocity, you
cannot tell whether or not
the train car is moving or not.
Very important are the
development of clocks and times
and signal processing
of the time.
And we discussed this in the
context of trains and train
lines, but also in Einstein
living in the city of Bern,
with a large number
of clock towers
which needed synchronization.
And even working in
the patent office
certainly confronted him with
those questions all the time.
So time is suspect.
That is really the
key to moving out
from Galilean transformation
into Newtonian mechanics
to special relativity.
When we classify or when
we look at specific series,
we have to understand that
they live within a context,
within a range of validity.
And so classical
mechanics is not wrong
because it breaks down
at large velocities.
It's just only correct in
the frame of slow velocities.
And special relativity
also has its limitations,
as in it only describes
reference frames or scenarios
in which there is no
acceleration between two
reference frames.
Going back to the question
of the time, Michelson--
and a number of other
experiments leading to the very
same direction--
was trying to
establish that there
is an ether wind, a medium
in which light is moving.
And his experiment,
at the time, failed
to demonstrate that
ether actually exists.
His experiment used a light
source and a couple of mirrors
in order to show
interference patterns.
And those interference patterns
didn't manifest themselves.
So he thought for a long time
that his experiment is limited
or that he has made a mistake.
But it turns out that
ether indeed doesn't exist.
Einstein tackled this problem
by making two postulates.
The first one is the
principle of relativity,
that there is no preferred
reference frame if you want;
and the second, that the
speed of light is constant--
and constant and the same
in all reference frames.
And in this class we use
those two postulates in order
to derive everything we know
about special relativity.
So we looked at
the implications.
And the implications
started from time dilation,
length contractions.
We were able to derive the
Lorentz factor and Lorentz
transformation.
And we did this by showing
this light clock here,
where you observe a ticking
clock in which there
is two mirrors and
light bouncing back.
And each time there
is a bounce, we
count this as one
tick of the clock.
So if the clock is
moving, the light
has to travel a longer distance.
And hence time is delayed.
And from just the
geometry of this problem,
we were able to derive
this gamma factor here--
1 over square root of
1 minus beta squared.
The beta is velocity
over the speed of light.
So as the first activity
in today's class,
I want you to think
about a clock which
is moving with a
photon, a clock which is
moving with the speed of light.
And also discuss why isn't
it possible to go faster
than the speed of light.
And why can you not
just keep accelerating?
So think about
this a little bit.
In the live class we
will have a discussion.
But just come up with
some sort of answer
of why this is the case.
So here we have, in
the class, actually
showed that there
is a real speed
limit, that if you
try to go faster,
past [INAUDIBLE]
velocity, you run
against a boundary,
a real speed limit.
If you think about keeping
accelerating, giving
more energy, you
find that the amount
of energy you need in order to
go faster and faster, faster,
doesn't get you to velocities
which are faster and faster.
And again, you enter a speed
limit-- the speed of light.
An important topic
in understanding
some of the paradoxes
in special relativity,
and some of the
confusion, is the concept
of the relativity
of simultaneity.
Now, it can be illustrated quite
nicely in this example here,
where you have a carriage train
car with light being emitted
and clocks which record those
events at each end of the train
car.
For the stationary person,
those clocks will tick in sync.
They will always show the
same tick and the same time.
But for somebody who's observing
this train from a platform,
or somebody who's moving
with a relative velocity
towards this train car, you
will see those clocks not
ticking at the same time.
So the clear evidence
is given in this picture
again, where you see that
the light's being emitted
in the center, but one side
of the train car is hit first
and the second side
is hit afterwards.
So you see that the
leading clock lags.
The leading clock in
this example lags behind.
And so what you find
here is that events which
are observed simultaneously
for one observer--
in this case, the person
inside the carriage--
they will not be simultaneous
for an observer who's moving
with a relative velocity.
And that led us to the
understanding of the pole
in the barn paradox, where,
in one example, the event
of the front of the pole
hitting the back of the barn
and the event of the
back of the pole hitting
the front of the barn,
they are simultaneously
for the barn owner.
But they're not simultaneously
happening for the person
who's carrying the pole.
In this case, the event of
hitting the back of the barn
is simultaneous to an event
where the back of the pole
is still sticking
out of the barn.
So there is a
clear disagreement.
But the disagreement
can be resolved
by understanding that
simultaneous events are not
necessarily simultaneous
to two observers.
Then we moved on to a
variety of other paradoxes
in special relativity.
And the most famous likely
is the twin paradox,
where we discussed that a person
moving away and then returning
is younger than the person
who actually stayed at rest.
And we discussed that we were
able to use time dilation
or length contraction in order
to quantitatively figure out
the difference in time.
But we also discussed
that the person
who is moving away
and then coming back
needs to describe the journey in
two different reference frames.
And from the fact that
you don't consistently can
describe this sequence
of events as two
reference frames
can see the paradox
and the extra confusion.
So here we have
another activity--
an asymmetric travel.
So we discussed also the example
where two people move away
and then they come back
in a symmetric fashion.
But here we want
to discuss the case
where there are three trends.
Carol stays on Earth.
Bob moves to Star 1.
And Alice moves to Star 2.
The distance to Star 1 is longer
than the distance to Star 2.
So the question is, in this
journey, they both start
and they both return at
the same time for Carol.
But which of the
twins is the youngest?
So again, I invite you
to just work this out.
You can use some numbers if
you want a quantitative answer.
Or you can just reason
about [INAUDIBLE]..
The answer here is that Bob
is the youngest of the three
once they return to Earth.
And the reason for this is
the distance he has to travel
is the longest.
Hence the velocity he has
to travel in is the largest.
And hence the effect of
time dilation for him
is the biggest.
And therefore he's going to
be the youngest of the three.
All right.
We had a rather long discussion
about waves and light, Doppler
effect, and relativistic
Doppler effect.
Here, just as a
reminder, the wave
equation for an electric
field in a vacuum.
And the solution to
the wave equation
is use the second derivative
with space and time.
And the solution
simply can be expressed
as a cosine, which is a
function of space and time.
We have talked about
light quite a bit.
And just as
reminder, [INAUDIBLE]
the energy of photon is
related via the Planck-Einstein
relation to the frequency.
So the higher the frequency,
the higher the energy.
The higher the frequency,
And here, in this
picture, you can
see the effect of
the Doppler effect,
where, when you have
a moving source,
the observer sees the
waveline modified.
Objects which move
towards us are
blueshifted, starting
from white light,
or green light in this example.
And objects that move away
from us are redshifted.
The effect can be
used, for example,
in speed measurements of cars.
It can also be used in order
to measure speed or distances
of stars moving away from us.
And so that defines,
then, the concept
of redshift, which is simply
the ratio of the difference
in wavelength divided
by the wavelength as
observed by the observer.
So here there's two
concept questions.
The first one is, is
the wave equation,
which you can see
there as an example,
invariant under
Lorentz transformation?
And the second question is,
how about the solutions?
Are the solutions
to the wave equation
invariant under
Lorentz transformation?
So I'll have you
work this out again.
And the answers are yes and no.
The wave equation is invariant.
The wave equation
describes the physics.
It explains how electric
and magnetic fields change.
And the laws of physics
need to be invariant
under Lorentz transformation.
Otherwise they
will not be valid.
They will violate the postulate
we just made that all reference
frames are equal to each other.
However, the solutions of the
wave equation-- light itself--
is not invariant under
Lorentz transformation.
We've just discussed
redshift and blueshift,
which means that the wavelength
and frequency of light
changes with respect to the
observer, or for each observer.
So the solutions-- light--
are not invariant under
Lorentz transformation.
And then we went a little
bit into particle physics.
And I have to apologize
for my own preference.
But elementary
particles, as they
have been reproduced
or observed,
are typically moving at
rather large velocities.
So they are very good
examples to study
effects of special relativity.
We looked at energy, the
total energy m0 gamma c
squared, which also
can be expressed
as the energy of the rest
energy of the particle,
m0 c squared, plus
the kinetic energy.
And we looked at
the total energy
as being invariant, one
of those invariants,
as equal to the total
momenta squared.
The total energy squared is
equal to the total momentum
squared times c squared
plus the rest mass squared
times c to the fourth power.
And then we went through a
larger number of examples,
from accelerating electrons
to composite particles.
We talked about deuteron
photon absorption and emission,
the creation of particle, the
creation of antiparticles,
and the scattering of particles.
So here we had another example.
Oops-- without the solution.
In 1995, at Fermilab, a
proton-antiproton collider,
the Tevatron, top
quarks were discovered.
And we measured the top
quark mass to 175 GeV.
The center of mass
energy at the Tevatron
was 1.8, and later almost
2 tera-electronvolt,
and clearly sufficient for the
production of top and antitop.
But what is the minimal energy
in order for this process
to occur?
And here we went through
a number of examples.
The minimal energy-- sorry.
I have to work this out again.
The minimal energy required
can be derived or extracted
in the center of mass frame,
where the top and antitop are
produced at rest.
And if you do this--
in this example,
the proton in this
collider experiment--
the experiment is
already conducted
in the center of mass frame.
So the minimal energy
is simply 2 times
the top mass times c square,
or 2 times gamma times the mass
of the proton times c
square, which gives you
a gamma factor of 175.
But the likelihood
to actually observe
a top quark and a antitop
quark at that energy, 175 GeV
proton or antiproton
energy, is rather 0.
And the reason for this has
to do with the structure
of the proton.
The actual interaction between
the proton and the antiproton
is such that the quarks and
antiquarks inside the proton,
and also the gluons, interact.
And they only carry a
fraction of the momentum
and the energy of the proton.
And hence this
minimal calculation
is insufficient to get a
sufficient cross-section
likelihood for top quarks and
antiquarks to be produced.
But that is particle physics
and goes beyond the scope
of this lecture.
One last point, which leads
sometimes to confusion,
is the concept of conserved
and invariant properties.
When we look at the
meaning of the word,
invariant means never-changing.
And in the concept of
special relativity,
properties are invariant
when they do not
change under Lorentz
transformation or Galilean
transformation, as we
discussed earlier in the class.